c'est un peu mou pour soir un sou sent
qu'il ya pas de fatigue alors compter
chez moi j'ai très très heureux d'être
là même si parler en 18 minutes ça va
être un challenge pour moi je suis très
heureux d'être là et puis quand j'ai
envie de vous demander un truc vous avez
au commencement il ya des chaînons iliad
en rêve tout ça chez les aborigènes ya
le rêve un commencement était le rêve un
geste irréfléchi qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qui était de rêve pour les uns et les
autres quand on était petit alors pour
les garçons c'est être gendarme au
camion de pompier formateur à pour les
filles et un fils mais moi mon rêve
c'était de chef d'orchestre dire comment
ça m'est revenue j'en sais rien me
demandez pas mais mon rêve était de chef
d'orchestre et d'être chef d'orchestre
suivant le comment dire l'image qu'on en
avait bien entendu chef d'orchestre et
donc je sauvagement
j'ai beaucoup ventilé ma chambre quand
j'étais petit voyez ce que je veux dire
à diriger les symphonies de beethoven de
prince était un grand geste dans ma
chambre tout à fait incontrôlés et
incontrôlables à mais l'effet d'une
passion puis j'ai effectivement je me
suis lancé dans les études j'ai fait
j'ai fait ça ben pas malade et j'ai
beaucoup diriger et puis j'ai eu un
premier maître en fait en direction nord
qu'est ce qui m'a appris à être chef
d'orchestre tels que vous imaginez qu'un
chef d'orchestre c'est elle que tout le
monde se l'imaginent l'homme debout var
où l'homme où la femme maintenant aussi
mais debout devant en minorité les
femmes suis désolé
pour l'instant minorité mais c'est comme
les chefs d'entreprise n'a pas non plus
tant que ça c'est des grandes
entreprises
pas tant que ça vous êtes d'accord avec
moi mesdemoiselles mesdames donc un
montreux mais m j'ai eu m un peu austère
m'a appris à faire des beaux gestes
je pense que l'idée on donne le départ
donc l'idée du chef coordinateur du chef
sémaphore du cheval très bien et puis
j'ai commencé à diriger comme ça sur
deux mois qui compte vraiment brand
celui qui incarnait quelque chose
vraiment le chef d'orchestre du xxème
siècle peut pas dire mieux puis j'ai un
deuxième m est arrivé j'ai étudié avec
les états unis étaient français mais il
est dirigé une école aux états unis et
lui m'a pas beaucoup bousculé sur deux
choses puisqu'on avait une particularité
dans cette école c'est qu'on devait tout
faire partie de leur caisse quand on ne
dirigeait pas donc c'est un peu le stage
en entreprise voyez ce que je veux dire
et puis en même temps en même temps on
avait aussi bas quand tu es devant leurs
caissons avait soixante musiciens devant
nous et puis le maître qui était à
dizaines de 10 15 m de nouveaux fonds
d'orchestre qui pouvait nous arrêter à
tout moment et qui nous arrêtent et pas
forcément de façon toujours soft on va
dire donc ça pouvait des grands
hurlements couvrez leurs cases en
symphonie de brahms et là vous avez
intérêt à vous arrêter
croyez moi jusqu'au jour il m'a arrêté
et marc est comme ça qui m'a dit qu'est
ce qui se passe à la mesure 33 au
deuxième au bois qu'est ce qui s'est
passé voilà c'est première chose c'est
quoi la mesure 33
donc prenez la partition regarde être je
ne sais pas et vous voulez être chef
d'orchestre vous imaginez quatre chefs
d'orchestre c'est juste bouger ses bras
et dimna chef d'orchestre chef
d'orchestre c'est avant tout écouter
leurs castres et transmettre une émotion
mais c'est être capable d'écouter
ma vie à faire a continué à faire un
choix et je suis interrogé sur
finalement c'est équilibré on se rend
compte que c'était extrêmement
excessivement difficile d'être entre
comment j'écoute et comment je donne et
qu'est-ce que je dois donner
et quel est le niveau de confiance que
doit donner alors qu'est ce qu'elle est
le niveau d'engagement que je peux avoir
moi etc
quel niveau de contrôle toutes ces
questions qui arrive en pagaille
derrière parce que quand vous êtes en
train de faire le chef d'orchestre ça
c'est facile à diriger
mais quand vous devenez d'un coup
quelque part un musicien parmi d'autres
musiciens avec juste la fonction diriger
la vous arrivez à autre chose tiens vous
propose un petit exercice je vous
demander vos mains vos mains libres s'il
vous plaît est pas complètement vautré
sur votre chaise
6 po si possible je vous demandais juste
de taper dans les mains tous en même
temps
je vous arrête alors qu'est ce qui s'est
passé vous avez deux choses comme moi la
même chose que moi au début le chaos et
ensuite un ordre qui s'établit de
d'accord cet ordre qui s'établit grâce à
quoi
premier réflexe vous avez remarqué c'est
nos oreilles vos oreilles qui vous ont
dit comment on solution des problèmes
formidable donc les coups tu nous as
l'air de nous sortir de problème pas
forcément prévu maintenant pourquoi ce
chaos
dia bâ on ne savait pas quand quand
est-ce qu'il fallait démarrer le top
départ à quelle vitesse et j'ai d'accord
hélas si je demande la faute à qui à
vrai dire au chef d'orchestre bien
entendu bien entendu alors nous sommes
d'accord chez madame au 20e siècle
j'en prends la responsabilité totale au
21ème siècle n'en renvoie une partie
qu'est ce que vous auriez pu faire me
demander les règles du jeu vous aurez vu
quelqu'un dans la salle aurait pu se
lever et crier avec moi et puis et tout
le monde aurait suivi il ya plein de
choses qui étaient possibles
et pourtant on reste dans notre chacun
date de son côté c'est juste pas
possible on est au 21ème siècle ce qu'on
est ce qu'on va produire ensemble dépend
de chacun alors je vous donnais les
règles puis on recommence
alors si vous faites mieux d'après voilà
les règles vous allez taper
simultanément autant de temps que je ne
vous arrête pas et pour vous faire
démarrer j'ai compté 1 2 3 pour 1 ne le
fait pas le fait pas le fait pas je vous
montre pour l'instant donc 1 2 3 pomme
rouge ou non mais si je fais un deux
trois packs pack 1 2 3
ok j'ai compris pour la nuance
pareil si je hurle 1 2 3 vous taper très
fort et puis la manière pour qu'on soit
bien 12 d'accord vous taper dans les
mains
quatre doigts dedans une main ok non
vérifiées pas à monsieur juste c'est pas
la peine vous allez y arriver chisya
mama la moitié qui la fait bien vous
êtes prêts à les règles sont claires
pour tout le monde c'est parti je compte
1 2 3 je ne fais rien de plus vous allez
vous débrouiller 1 2 3
merci et qu'est ce que nous constatons
qu avec des règles ça va beaucoup mieux
donc effectivement rôle du chef
d'orchestre départ s'est donné des
règles mais les règles ne sortent pas de
notre fait en sorte de la partition
quand même et puis deuxième rôle
derrière vous avez remarqué
je pense pour la plupart d'entre vous
que ça a commencé à accélérer la marque
et on pas très violent j'ai connu pire
hein mais s'accélère et moi ça
m'intéresse
l'accélération m'intéresse parce que si
je vous demande qui a accéléré surtout
pas vous évidemment je vois quelqu'un
qui pointe son voisin jamais vous bien
entendu c'est comme les éoliennes c'est
mieux chez les voisins 1
évidemment vous êtes une centaine dans
cette salle vous avez un centième de
responsabilité dans l'accélération
si je demande maintenant comment est-ce
qu'on va corriger ne pas accélérer après
la fois d'après vous allez me dire il
faut un chef d'orchestre vous êtes
d'accord
il y en action tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord avec ça win chef d'orchestre
vous voulez un ou une chef d'orchestre
ou quelqu'un qui va être un référentiel
nous nous sommes tous d'accord là dessus
et là je dis bande d'assistés bande de
gens qui ont l'habitude quand il parle
on va demander aux chefs
comment on fait j'ai la prétention ici
que vous y arriviez sans moi le trait
qu'est ce que vous allez faire pour y
arriver
s'écouter et faire quelque chose que
vous n'avez pas fait devenir responsable
résultats coresponsable des résultats
acteurs qu acteur voyez ce genre de truc
parce que maintenant imaginer il ya deux
mille personnes derrière nous qui veut
l'entendre un seul bruit qui n'accepte
pas c'est parti ce que vous attendez
attendez je compte 1 2 3 il ya des
enthousiastes a remis jouer un deux
trois
ouais c'est vachement mieux c'est
vachement bien qu'est ce qu'on observe
votre attitude qui a changé la première
fois que de taper dans les mains comme
ça et là étiez vous reconnaissez je les
ai même vu des ça va donc vous voyez
vous y arriver sans moi très bonne
nouvelle vous pouvez y arriver sans moi
très mauvaise nouvelle c'est pour moi
mais alors une fois que j'ai donnée car
à quoi sert un chef d'orchestre et là je
vous propose de l'expérimenté vous me
suivez
d'accord joue pas la mesure vous me
suivez 1 2 3 est ce que vous allez faire
ça sans moi réponse évidemment vous avez
raison la réponse est oui mais avec due
à la répétition
or vous savez peut-être mesdames
messieurs pour obtenir qu'un orchestre
soit prêt pour un concert nous avons
trois jours de répétition quatre jours
c'est donc très court donc il faut être
très efficace vous y aider il faut y
aller et se mettre vraiment tout de
suite en mouvement les musiciens juge le
chef sur leur efficacité
alors on va un peu plus loin je refais
l'exercice une dernière fois 1 2 3
et c'est vous aurez peur ça vous aurait
pas pu le faire sans moi même avec une
partition nous rentrons dans la
complexité et donc mon rôle de chef
d'orchestre c'est de gérer et de vous
emmener dans la complexité et au lieu de
faire le rôle du chef d'orchestre
ordonnateur d'un coup je deviens le chef
d'orchestre guide celui qui montre le
chemin
mais maintenant si je vous demande
comment vous vous êtes écouter et
comment vous êtes vous senti responsable
depuis je vous dirige vous dire bah on
s'aimera j'm'en moins écoutés parce que
vous m'avez suivi et on sait moins senti
responsable parce que parce que vous
m'avez suivi c'est moi qui porte la
responsabilité
nous sommes d'accord là dessus alors
nous arrivons au coeur du problème tant
et tant que je ne suis pas intervenu
nous avons travaillé ensemble avec un
petit exercice a créé un lien
horizontale entre vous fait d'écouter
effet de coaction on a créé ce lien
horizontale entre vous dès lors que
j'arrive le lien horizontale se délite
au profit du vertical et nous sommes
typiquement dans un comportement
classique passé 20e siècle c'est à dire
ou l'horizontale ou de vertical mais pas
et et le problème c'est que maintenant
au 21ème siècle qu'est ce qui se passe
mal horizontale il est là quoi qu'on ait
quoi que nous voulions l'horizontale et
là il est incarné vous êtes beaucoup ici
vous êtes beaucoup et beaucoup de jeunes
ici vous en être typiquement cette jeune
génération d y des aides qui arrivent
encore plus derrière c'est à dire des
gens qui sont connectés qui sont de
toute façon qui vivent dans
l'horizontale il fait que toute façon
vous ne demandez jamais à vos parents le
mode d'emploi ni à un professeur un mode
d'emploi quelconque vous avez demandé
aux copains au forum au réseau mais
surtout pas au dessus on va chercher au
dessus les musiciens font pareil ils
vont chercher la solution à côté un jour
mon dea musiciens du philharmonique de
berlin qu'est-ce que vous jouez il a
répondu nous on joue la troisième
symphonie de schumann
il a montré de chef il a dû lui on sait
pas aller c'est à dire que l'orchestré
leur caisse se connecte alors la
question c'est comment passer de l'un à
l'autre et est ce qu'on peut imaginer
effectivement qu'on ne soit pas le
vertical contrôle horizontale mais l'un
et l'autre évidemment mais cela suppose
un changement radical de posture
tant de la part du chef d'orchestre que
de la part des musiciens nous allons
quitter cette version verrouillée avec
le chef dominant orchestre au profit de
quelque chose de beaucoup plus mobile
qui va s'adapter à la complexité mais
qui va supposer d'autres choses que vous
êtes ce système de règles eric julien
parlais tout à l'heure des règles on
fait des lois les règles là on rentre
dans un monde de valeur un monde de
valeurs qui sont faits sur l'écoutent
sur la confiance la bienveillance
l'adaptabilité la souplesse l'humilité
pour le chef ce qui n'est pas forcément
une qualité de base et puis côté
orchestre
quant au chef d'orchestre se met en
position basse c'est alors qu'istres est
en position haute
et là nous avons nous rentrons dans une
logique de responsabilisation
d'orchestre responsabilisation prise de
risque davantage d' écoute davantage de
confiance et c'est là nous avons un
enjeu capital dans les orchestres
évidemment nous l'avons mais vous faites
la transposition dans tous les domaines
où nous trouvons on peut plus être comme
ça nous avons besoin le chef
traditionnel peut s'effacer à condition
que leur qu'istres et donc chaque
musicien de leur caisse devienne acteur
de son futur donc il se passe des choses
ça vous va ou pas commis d un peu près
clair ou pas si mal et donc je voudrais
vous présenter maintenant un petit film
un petit film qui va permettre
d'illustrer ça il ya 40 ans il ya 40 ans
exactement au venezuela s'est créé un
organisme
répondant au doux nom de el sistema el
sistema est un organisme créé par un
visionnaire ce procès manuel antonio
abreu qui a eu cette idée juste génial
de sortie à des gamins de la violence
endémique dans laquelle ils vivaient
dans les favelas ce en leur faisant
faire de la musique ensemble
il a commencé à créer d orchestre
d'enfants aujourd'hui les chiffres - le
chiffre aux moyens ces quatre cent mille
jeunes qui font de la musique au
venezuela grâce à cette organisation qui
répond au doux nom de el sistema le
système bien entendu
c'est un système puisque chacun est
intégrée là dedans et ce système a à
deux ambassadeurs dans le monde
un orchestre et un chef d'orchestre la
particularité d'un système à c'est
précisément de transformer un impossible
le monde dans lequel ils s'étaient tous
ces jeunes a priori cette violence la
drogue et c'est la misère la pauvreté
qui est pour beaucoup de ces gens là
normalement une fatalité de la
transformer en quelque chose de possible
et ce quelque chose de possible est
devenu tellement possible que le monde
entier actuellement ça commence est en
train de s'inspirer de ce qu'ils font au
venezuela à partir de el sistema du
modèle el sistema el systema france
existe el sistema états unis existe il
ya plus de 50 pays
aujourd'hui travaillent sur ce modèle
alors plutôt que vous en faire des
discours
j'ai envie de plus tôt vous amener un
petit film pour vous montrer el systema
en action avec ces deux ambassadeurs l'
orchestre des jeunes simon bolivar est
le chef d'orchestre gustavo dudamel né
en 1981
patron depuis 2009 du philharmonique de
los angeles
je vous invite à passer deux minutes à
peu près avec tchaïkovski
alors que cet orchestre et ce chef
d'orchestre bien on conclura derrière
s'il vous plaît
non
on
alors on pourrait regarder ça longtemps
même si on n'aime pas spécialement la
musique classique mais qu'est ce qui -
qu'est-ce qui me frappe et qu'est ce qui
me bouleverse quand je vois c'est quand
je les vois eux et quand je vois le chef
d'orchestre c'est qu'ils sont vivants
qui a quelque chose de formidablement
vivant vous avez le plan avec les deux
les deux violonistes à la fin vous avez
l'engagement de ses musiciens chacun et
mais comme si comme si chaque musicien
mettez dans sa vie dans ce qu'il est en
train de faire et peut-être que c'est ce
que nous avons besoin nous réapprendre
en occident et si dans les pays dits
développés laisse penser à retrouver
ceux vivant à retrouver cette nécessité
d'être vivant d'être dans cette pièce
d'urgence qui fait que à la fois
individuellement et à la fois
collectivement ils sont en train de
transformer le monde parce que là il ya
un projet politique derrière parce que
claude hamel dans les interviews parle
de paix parle de fraternité parce que
abreu qui a été le cas donc lancé ce
mouvement a eu le prix nobel alternatif
ya quelques années par pour toutes ces
raisons il ya quelque chose de l'ordre
d' exceptionnelle qui est en train de se
vivre là à travers ça mais c'est juste
croisé le système en action et elle je
vous ai pas amener la vidéo la plus
forte parce que enfin la plus forte la
plus forte c'est un autre genre et je
vous invite à vous rendre sur youtube
pour regarder le mambo de west side
story avec le même orchestre même chef
d'orchestre à caracas en 2007 et vous
assistez en plus aux délires du public
parce que public est juste complètement
dedans
il est il participe à l'aventuré et nous
avons un quelque chose qui danse quelque
chose qui vit voilà j'ai envie de
partager vous merci beaucoup de votre
attention
merci